this would have been unthinkable under
the previous taliban regime
a female anchor interviewing a member of
the hardline islamic group
back in power the taliban seems to be on
a pr mission to reassure the country and
the world afghan women's rights will be
respected
anyone who worked against the militants
will be forgiven
and afghanistan will never again harbor
terrorists the taliban spokesperson told
sky news girls will go to school unlike
20 years ago in afghanistan there were
thousands of schools of girls schools
universities they all are operating
for women and girls in afghanistan it's
hard to believe
when the taliban last ruled strict
islamic law was imposed requiring them
to stay home
only allowed out in a burka accompanied
by a male relative this time the taliban
say women don't have to wear a full
burka just a headscarf the claims met by
some with cautious optimism i appreciate
their kind gesture of
calling out women to
come back to their workplaces and
schools and universities
but uh they should give us this right to
to be still uncertain to be still
confused and to to to still be afraid
because it's not easy for us
um
looking into their reputation and their
previous regime
i think it will not be easy for a one
woman to
to all of a sudden come out and
restart their normal lives
the message for anyone who worked for
the toppled afghan government security
forces but even for countries like the
uk is also conciliatory
even though we know they told us
not
ten not hundreds of thousands of us were
killed by them but
we still announced a general
amnesty actions not words and
the action
the
sound louder than words
this scramble to leave afghanistan a
sign that many doubt these words
or that the taliban leadership can
control the actions of their foot
soldiers
and then there's the question of
terrorism
the taliban claims afghanistan will
never again be a haven for groups like
al qaeda
but a recent u.n report warned up to 500
al-qaida fighters were thought to be in
the country their ties with the taliban
run deep
the risk of a resurgent threat all too
real debra haines sky news